so many people when they actually travel
from the u.s to europe and they consume
wheat products they have no bloating
they don't have near the digestive
problems they don't even necessarily
gain weight now i am definitely not
recommending consuming wheat but i want
to talk about the difference between
wheat from america versus wheat from
europe there's a huge difference when
people are consuming breads and pastas
and cereals and crackers and biscuits in
the united states they get acne they get
bloating they get a lot of inflammation
in their gut they also have lethargy
they're tired but you don't really see
as much of that in europe at least from
the wheat why is that what is the
differences well in america sixty
percent of the wheat is red wheat now
what is red wheat compared to certain
countries in europe they use white wheat
so red wheat is soft it's fluffy it has
a longer shelf life it has a lot more
carbohydrate and it has much more
protein specifically gluten
the wheat that they use in europe has
much less gluten that's the protein
in wheat that causes a lot of the
problems in the gut but that's not the
only difference in america the wheat is
not necessarily genetically modified but
they use glyphosate in a lot of the
wheat which is the chemical they
normally spray on genetically modified
crops
now they say glyphosate is not harmful
to humans it's only harmful to bacteria
but the problem is humans have a lot of
bacteria growing inside and outside
their bodies in fact humans are
dependent on their microorganisms
so glyphosate directly attacks this
microbiome and disturbs the flora
and the ability for someone to digest
now gmo foods in general and glyphosate
is banned in many european countries now
there's one more point i want to bring
up but it has to do with iron
fortification so in grain products that
are refined they tend to fortify it with
synthetic vitamins and
iron
and of course the source of iron that
they're using to fortify is actually not
the type that your body can easily break
down
this type of iron that's fortified in
wheat in america kind of sits in your
gut
it tends to generate more pathogenic
bacteria and then if we compare this to
european countries like france
denmark and sweden and other countries
they use no fortification at all
so i just wanted to do this video to
talk about the difference from the
america versus european wheat of course
i'm not recommending consuming wheat i'm
just talking about the difference
so if you're enjoying my content which i
hope you are
and you're applying this knowledge to
your health
and you have a success i'd really
appreciate you sharing your success
story so click the link down below to my
website where you can upload your
success story so you can help inspire
others